[Music]
we have no choice but to bark hello I'm
Harry killer and I call Melanie Otto and
we're going to be interviewing our crew
stars on Fandango what the hootenanny is
going on you're gonna interview us about
that yeah good I've been waiting for
this moment my whole life who'd like to
begin this one's for Robert you've had
such an iconic film career what was it
about this product project that made you
say I need to be a part of this well
first of all we as I've said and as you
guys will see when we come in now we're
surrounded by animals cows alpacas goats
pigs chickens
that's just rabbit what kind of rabbit
is it a lion head rabbit yeah namely
Jasper well as it happened it was great
because we got to meet y'all and it's a
adventure film but it's period it's
live-action but then there's all the
animals and animations so we we like a
challenge and an adventure and this was
both so this is a question for romance
season a lot of a lot of this film is
you having conversations with your
friends who happen to be animals if you
guys could ask your pets one question
what would it be
I've got it I would ask Monty why did
you wake mrs. Downey up every morning at
5:30 and how can we fix this I would do
a side deal with him so I would probably
ask
d'Artagnan dark or other cat Monty's
brother yeah I would be like I just want
to know if he's happy because you cannot
read that cat at all he's a tough beat
he's a tough read and he seems really
shy but I actually think like in a
street fight he'd take down any other
cat but he seems like fluffy and nice
and all that so I just it's a simple
thing he's a sleeping dragon I'm so glad
you got that outfit and how are you I
were to connect and visualize the
animals that were being portrayed well
as you I mean you were up against it as
much as well and Carmel as well there
were animal actors as well as every
other reference you could have and so
there was a team of people dressed in
green suits who were really going for it
and it was sometimes so helpful and
sometimes I just felt so awkward too
because past a certain point in the day
you're like I'm just gonna look there
and do this but they're still dressed in
green and their butt and the thing is a
lot of these folks are really highly
trained actors that were coming off Star
Wars and they're coming they're all like
amazing folks but it's that it's that
ability to to pretend you know which is
half of what we're doing which of the
cost members surprised you the most
without betrayal of their voice on that
character oh that's a good question
surprise for the most I would say
probably Rami mmm I would think because
the other ones I had such a clear idea
of like why we cast them and then they
delivered always better than I could
have even imagined but like like we
wanted this spicy squirrel so you get
Craig Robinson of course and we want
this duck with like a lot of energy and
like kind of like you don't know what
she's gonna say next and and a little
goofy and sock Tavia nailed it but with
Chi Chi we just we love Rami we're such
big fans of his and we knew we wanted to
be working with him and we knew that Chi
Chi and Doolittle had a special bond and
he adores Rami so we were like let's
let's do that but Rami as a gorilla I
said I didn't know what that mean it has
to go like yeah yeah so I think for
that's probably the one that that
surprised me the most that's a really
good answer another one for robots oh
good so you paid Sherlock Holmes are now
Doolittle yeah what classic character
would you like to portray Nix oh boy
I don't know we were toying around with
the idea of doing like a musical comedy
about Sir Walter Raleigh who was kind of
an arrow do well and and all that stuff
I should probably take a break from
Brits for a minute just because it would
seem like I have run out of moves yeah
I'll get back to you on that well
articulated good since you didn't get to
voice an animal in this film what animal
would you like to play if you got to
decide right god that's really good I
would like to be a swarm of insects
because that way I could make up the
fact I didn't get to do a single animal
voice on this so I could do you know
thousands really what they would do is
they would take my voice and they would
just repeat it I'd be harmonizing with
myself it'd be like a chorus yeah why
didn't you give me that opportunity
producer okay yeah next time I know I
went for a bit yes all right what was it
like teaming out with Tom Holland again
huh pretty great I mean we love a bit of
time don't we yeah we do yeah did a
great job with the with playing jib but
also I think a lot of people are just
comforted by the fact that they were
hearing our voices again after the
events in the Marvel Universe in this
like in case we don't have to be
reminded that what happens on a movie
screen isn't real although he did his
British accent for our movie that's
right yeah and there was talk of that
originally he was gonna do cockney then
he was doing British and then at the
last minute like wait should he do
American his Tom Holland accent was
exceptional so you guys are gonna do a
talk show now aren't you you're taking
you taking me to jail
you can talk to animals
Michael yes and since you didn't get to
voice an animal for this film if there
was an animal we'd like to voice which
one would it be
oh I I see a lot of sheep back in Wales
where I come from so maybe I would I
would like to voice a sheep I think I
feel a spiritual connection yeah and
this is for John and Craig how are you
were able to connect with the animals
you voiced in this film and where did
the inspiration for their voices come
from I slept in the park for three days
when we went into the record you know
how this goes you collaborating with the
producer and a director and it was a lot
of improv and you know going over the
lines and figured out where this
characters going and we found out that
Kevin was uh you know all about revenge
and so we based a lot of the humor there
oh she's a complicated dude okay
he's I mean I'm I'm telling everybody to
kind of embrace the Yosh because he's a
polar bear yet he's cold but at the same
time he's this big assuming creature
that's really loving and in search of
friends and is very in tune to the sense
of community so I I kind of dug that and
I think very similar with Craig's
experience you have an outlying theme
like okay Kevin is out for revenge
yo CEO she is all about friendship and
positivity and it's just a simple word
like that that dictates your demeanor
how you deliver the lines just a simple
piece of advice if he's a positive
character it changes the whole thing and
he's so funny as well well thank you
favorite characters I appreciate string
this is a question for all of you a lot
of the film takes place on a boat out of
all of you who would be the best captain
cool not Nick I feel like you would be
no I probably be good at following
orders but I don't I don't is the poop
deck still what I think it is
[Laughter]
exactly exactly I wouldn't be me I don't
know are you good at sea good with water
I'm good with water yes I'll be better
and entertainment okay so if it was a
cruise cruising could be a cruise
entertainment game on okay so I think by
default it's you I guess sorry everyone
so we do have a lot of pirates in this
movie if you got approached by pirates
who'd be the first to run away I'd want
to join up I kept my parrot on my
shoulder and practice my arse I do a bit
of that I would run as fast as I could
I run really unorthodox it's not so
there are so many different animals in
this movie what were some of the most
interesting animal facts you learnt
while making this film if you learn any
I had an interesting scene with with a
with a an octopus in a tank oh yeah they
are fascinating creatures I saw it I saw
have you seen that video of an octopus
like getting into a little bottle thing
I think in getting the training huge so
that was a that was kind of interesting
the world of octopi I believe I believe
it is scientific fact that squirrels
live for most of their life with a sense
of revenge yeah so busy spoons all about
a voyage if you had to go on a read on
voyage what snack would you take on it
[Laughter]
what's not going to do well if it was a
long voyage you'd have to have something
that would take a long time to eat what
are those things that those um like
meaty things that take forever to be
jerky is it like a beef jerky something
like that maybe I want to take a
charcuterie plate I was gonna say a
wheel of cheese so if you combine the
both that's a charcuterie plate yeah
she's
eating some crackers spreads bon voyage
yes mrs. mustard this film is all about
a voyage and a long journey so what was
the longest trip or adventure you guys
have ever been on
I once flew to New Zealand Wow and it's
such a long flight you can't do it in
one go you have to keep stopping all the
time and I remember we had to stop at a
few different airports and because of
the time difference I watched the Sun
come up three times that's actually
which was kind of a mystery in a safe I
just watched even give a story very good
I drove across country yeah a couple
times I drove a both East and West ago
from Los Angeles to Boston and then from
Boston to Florida Boston to Miami one of
my favorite voices you've ever done the
coastal star like tour the train from LA
all the way up the coast it goes up to
Seattle and then goes on into Canada and
it takes like a few days and you can
sleep on the train ah that's amazing
that's a great voice I would highly
recommend so thank you guys so much for
doing this interview thank you and go
watch Doolittle in cinemas January 17
yep oh I see
you